[Musique]
c'est à l'en-tête de saint denis que
l'artiste car google n'est présente
machinerie photographes créateurs
visuels qui nous dévoile et nous fait
découvrir à audard particulier derrière
l'objectif
l'exposition machine rouge est une
perception unique et atypique à travers
la photographie elle nous invite à un
voyage et nous transporte dans un monde
à multiples visages mon idée avec ses
expositions c'était de présenter
différents niveaux de deux réalités
différentes
différents niveaux de réalité de ce pays
de ce pays
et pourquoi donc ce titre machine je
fais référence d'une part évidemment ce
regard c'est mon regard donc c'est marc
chine et aussi je fais référence au fait
qu'une société c'est aussi comme une
mécanique une une société aussi c'est
une mécanique qui tourne le département
de la réunion accompagne les artistes en
favorisant la diversité et le partage de
la culture
c'est ce que nous rappelle madame
civisme au vice président délégué aux
affaires culturelles
et c'est pour dire aussi que dans le
cheminement que nous faisons avec les
artistes
nous accompagnons l'artiste et je tiens
aussi à dire que sur le projet de
mandature des résidences d'artistes
on a accompagné les artistes qui ont
répondu à des appels à projets on le
suit dans son parcours et à travers
différents dispositifs
à travers ces bourses qu'on met en place
pour permettre la réalisation de cette
résidence mais aussi à travers l'achat
d'oeuvres l'artiste réunionnais
l'artiste réunionnais est au centre de
nos préoccupations au département
l'exposition machine rouge est en ce
moment à l'artothèque de saint denis
à découvrir jusqu'au 5
[Musique]